hi there steve here steve kaufman
today i'm going to talk about
problems
we have in languages and how we can
overcome them
with particular reference to tenses all
right and in english but also to some
extent in other languages first of all
let me say that i'm
sitting here in front of this
print of a van gogh painting of a cafe
in al
from the 19th century
and regardless of the mistakes that we
make when we speak languages a knowledge
of these languages enables us to enjoy
so many things in those languages in
those cultures for example last night my
wife and i watched le journal
which is a
movie which takes place in normandy
based on a novel by octave
and it's just lovely to be
launched into that environment
and to understand the dialogue and so
forth and so on so we can make mistakes
when we speak we can still enjoy the
languages in so many ways but
obviously we like to speak as well as we
can
however
speaking with mistakes doesn't prevent
us from communicating or shouldn't
but i do notice the same kinds of
mistakes for example german people
typically say i am living here since
many years which is
fine in german zeit
yeah
but doesn't work in english i have i
have been living here for so many years
okay uh
french friends said when when you will
come to paris i will take you out but of
course in english we say
when you come to paris i will take you
out so we have to get used to the
phrasing the use of words the use of
tenses in other languages
one of the things and even the
subjunctive which we talked about you
know ifocu
ainda ke in portuguese
there are certain
words that trigger certain tenses or
certain forms of the verb
and so you can call these signal words
or trigger words so just for the fun of
it
i
googled
to see if i could find either trigger
words or signal words for different
tenses and lo and behold there are lots
of resources like this so for example
with regard to english
you know words like often seldom
sometimes usually they all trigger the
simple present i often
go i sometimes play
i usually
do all right however
words like at the moment
listen now
that's the progressive now i am eating
all right
so uh the simple past is
in 2010 yesterday whereas the the um
present perfect as it's called i have
whatever eaten already i have already
eaten i have
so far i haven't done any uh up to now
so all i'm saying is you should i will
maybe leave a link and i found one for
spanish for example uh
similarly what triggers the imperfect
versus the past tense so you need to go
and search for these depending on what
your native language is depending on
what language you're learning in fact i
won't leave a link you should get in the
habit of searching for these
trigger words signal words and you could
even take the term trigger word or
signal word and translate it
in
google translate and then go off and
search for
a handy list of words that will help you
appreciate when a certain tense is
triggered
now even if you do that if you
understand that okay that word triggers
this that won't enable you to use it
correctly
and
you know and the reason for that is that
we have to develop these habits that's
why
i always in link i will save a phrase
with the trigger word collect it you
know tag it collect it and review it
trying to get my brain to notice it so
that when i hear it
and read it and eventually i start to
use it but let's be realistic it takes a
lot of practice a lot and i noticed this
for example i uh last two evenings i've
had conversations in ukrainian
and the ukrainian grammar is very
similar to russian grammar
but some of the endings are different
plus
obviously that some of the words are
different
and
so while the principle is the same
when i
use a word that's supposed to be in a
certain case
my brain is just not in the habit of
doing that in ukrainian so i end up just
giving the base word it's as if me go
home do like just throwing in you know
the word because the brain is not yet
confident enough and is not trained
enough to do it correctly even though
the principles are the same as in
russian okay one of something is the
nominative 2 3 4 of something is the
genitive singular five and more is the
genitive plural that's the rule in all
slavic languages for nouns and yet i can
do it in russian but when i go to do it
in ukrainian the brain hasn't done it
before it's like an exercise whether it
be doing roles on a mat or something you
actually have to
hear it so often that the phrase rings
in your brain and when you go to do it
you do it correctly once and then you do
it correctly another time now however
you at least have to be interested in
getting it right and that's why if i go
back to the many people i know who are
fluent speakers uh say german speakers
swedish people who speak fluent english
and they'll say it is a lot of people in
china instead of there are because
that's more similar to what happens in
swedish so to to change that they would
have to be aware of it focus on it
see it many many times start to do it
and eventually they'll get better and
better at at training a new habit
okay but getting back to my original
comment
uh i think was katolam said that a
language is the only thing worth knowing
poorly so to whatever extent you have
a knowledge of another language you can
start enjoying that language and so that
enjoyment is the main thing and you can
keep on working on improving your
accuracy
but the fact that you make mistakes
shouldn't detract from your enjoyment
however when you speak
i guess the main thing in speaking is
that we should be able to communicate
i'm going to leave
a link in the description box of the
french language debate
amongst the uh candidates for the
leadership of the conservative party of
canada
of the 14 people there i think there
were two francophones
there was one anglophone who spoke
french very well
right down to a guy who no one could
understand
what he was saying
so uh you can click on that link to see
the range of these conservative
candidates attempting either speaking
french well or attempting to speak
french well full marks to them for
trying but in there there's someone who
obviously is not communicating in the
language in fact i might extract his uh
presentation and make it a second link
so those of you who are interested
please have a look and it's not to laugh
at people although it is quite funny
this one gentlemen but it is to point
out that when we go to speak in a
language we have to at least make sure
we are at a level where people can
somehow make out what it is we're saying
when we are just not able to enunciate
anything we should continue to focus on
our input activities acquiring more
words
getting used to hearing the language so
that so that when we go to speak it we
have some point of reference all right
so with that then i leave you with a
thought if you want to get better at
these sort of nagging problems that
people have even people who speak quite
well
focus on the trigger words or signal
words review them and then just
get used to noticing them noticing them
so that you can gradually train your
brain to produce them
correctly there you go and if you like
these videos please subscribe bye for
now
[Music]
you